president biden is calling for
congressional action on gun control
after another mass shooting this time in
sacramento six people were killed and 12
others injured early sunday morning when
police say at least two people opened
fire outside crowded bars in the city's
downtown district the suspects are still
at large molly riehl from our cbs
affiliate kovr has more from sacramento
it's become an all too common sight
hoards of people running from gunfire we
buy people down i got another one hit
another gunshot
this latest crime scene just two blocks
away from the steps of california's
state capitol building in sacramento
investigators say multiple shooters
opened fire as crowds were streaming out
of closing bars early sunday morning
while a motive for the shooting has not
been identified police are also
reviewing this video of a large fight
that broke out right before the gunfire
it's unclear if the two are connected
in the aftermath family members and
friends rushed to the scene to try and
find missing loved ones that's where the
father of devossier turner learned his
son was among the casualties i
understand
he walked out the club and he walked
into and got shot
nationwide there have been 120 mass
shootings since the start of the year
that averages out to more than one a day
and it's the second mass shooting in
sacramento in just five weeks
it is a sickness in our culture
and we must do everything we can to heal
that sickness
investigators haven't yet said what
types of weapons were used in this
shooting this is the worst mass shooting
in sacramento history gail wow awful
story thank you very much molly riehl
from our affiliate that's kovr